I'm not an open market in Guayaquil
where people are preparing to dress for
the World Cup they're extraordinarily
excited about it they say that they know
that the eyes of the world will be on
their national team in the Opening match
of the World Cup that's the first time
that that's ever happened in fact
Ecuador doesn't usually make it to the
World Cup but this they say that
everything could change especially this
year because they have a very good team
a lot of very very young players one of
them Gonzalo Plata in fact has been
nicknamed the black Messi
Ecuador's largest city there's a frenzy
to obtain the national team's Jersey
before they sell out
every Ecuadorian is a fanatic about
football this woman confesses she's
buying a small one for her dog
football fever has taken over
because we're going to win by one nil
but twelve-year-old Jeremy disagrees
I think that in the first half will die
but in the second half we'll win two nil
thanks to Gonzalo Plata
he's referring to Ecuadorian football
Idol Gonzalo Plata who like almost the
entire team grew up in poverty
22 year old Lata now plays for Spain's
real viadolid and has bought his family
this new house where he keeps many of
his trophies
blacks whites mulattos from the
mountains to the coast we all become
like one like brothers
back in his old neighborhood they
haven't forgotten him
shows us a photo of Plata with her
grandson and says he's an inspiration
for other boys so they don't turn to
drugs and crime
two weeks ago the government declared a
state of emergency and a curfew here in
guayakil and two other provinces because
of uncontrollable gang violence
because of security concerns local
officials have had to cancel a huge Fan
Fest that they'd plan to host
all the same ecuadorians all over
Guayaquil are preparing for the big day
even the gangs have called for an
unofficial truce to allow people to
think of nothing else but the game
true Ecuador has never come close to
winning a World Cup but people young and
old tell us that this time they're sure
their team will take them further than
ever before
well I can tell you the jerseys are
starting to run out here in this stall
pretty soon in fact this is going to
look like one huge yellow blotch the
people of Guayaquil have had a pretty
tough time over the last couple of years
first there was the pandemic then the
rise in crime and now the state of
emergency precisely during the World Cup
but they are excited nonetheless and
they're going to meet at least two
impromptu fan fests being organized by
football clubs in the city one in the
north and one in the South where we're
expecting thousands of people to gather
and they say hopefully to celebrate the
victory over Qatar in The Opening match